Jerry Springer has died at the age of 79.
But what do we know about his death — and
the incredible, strange, and controversial
life he led?
The famous talk show host and mastermind behind
The Jerry Springer Show was diagnosed with
cancer a few months ago, but his condition
worsened earlier this week.
He was in his home, located in the Chicago
area, at the time of his passing.
A family spokesperson released a statement
on behalf of the talk show host's family,
noting he was loved by lots of people.
It read:
"Jerry's ability to connect with people was
at the heart of his success in everything
he tried.
[...] He's irreplaceable and his loss hurts
immensely, but memories of his intellect,
heart, and humor will live on."
Of course, Springer leaves behind an impressive
legacy.
While he was primarily associated with television,
he had a long career that saw him take on
a variety of jobs, ranging from political
pursuits to movie roles.
Prior to becoming one of the most recognizable
faces on television, Jerry Springer was a
politician and a supporter of the Democratic
Party.
After serving as Robert F. Kennedy's political
campaign adviser, he unsuccessfully ran for
Congress in 1970.
However, he was elected to Cincinnati City
Council the following year and became the
mayor of the city in 1977.
That said, he was only allowed to hold the
position of mayor for a year.
Most people associate Springer with his talk
show, which he hosted for 27 years.
The Jerry Springer Show rose to prominence
in the 1990s and attracted a lot of controversy
due to the topics it covered.
The series originally started out as a humble
political and news commentary show, but it
truly took off after it started covering stories
about… this kind of stuff.
*slap*
Critics often accused the show of being sensationalist
and exploitative, but millions of viewers
were captivated by its content.
It wasn't uncommon for the guests to start
fights with each other on The Jerry Springer
Show, but the drama helped the series become
a ratings smash in the United States.
Springer's controversial juggernaut even drew
more viewers than The Oprah Winfrey Show in
the late '90s, which was no small feat at
the time.
Springer's success turned him into a household
name, so it was only a matter of time until
he made the leap to acting.
While his political career only saw him work
at the local level, he did get to play the
president of the United States in Dolph Lundgren's
action-thriller The Defender.
For the most part, though, Springer was either
cast as himself or as characters with similar
interests to his own.
His most famous movie role is Ringmaster,
in which he portrays a talk show host named
Jerry Farrelly.
While the movie didn't set the box office
on fire, it did showcase Springer's abilities
as an actor and proved that he was more than
happy to satirize himself.
In 1999, he had a brief cameo in Austin Powers:
The Spy Who Shagged Me, in which he played
himself and interviewed Dr. Evil and his son.
"Okay, everything's okay.
Get this jerk out of here."
"I'll give you [bleep], you piece of [bleep]!"
Springer also guest starred on several TV
shows, from The X-Files to The Simpsons.
His final acting role was on The House Arrest
Rooneys, a comedy about a family that gets
caught up in an insurance fraud scam.
Meanwhile, his last general television appearance
was on The Masked Singer last year.
No doubt, Springer leaves behind a legacy
as unusual as the show that made him famous.